the movie revolves around a young couple
John and Alice who are struggling badly
with their finances life has become so
tough that they don't even have food in
the kitchen and the rent has been
overdue for months John actually has a
job at a marketing company but due to
his low self-esteem and high workload he
earns close to nothing to make matters
worse his boss always threatens to fire
him if he doesn't improve his sales on
the other hand Alice goes to regular job
interviews but she is always rejected
due to her lack of experience when she
is home the flirty landlord Arnie
usually arrives to collect rent and make
her feel bad he especially likes to
point out what a failure of a person her
husband is one night John and Alice
attend a fancy party without knowing the
dress code they reach there in casual
attire while everyone else is in formal
dress nevertheless they decide to stay
at the party which is hosted by one of
their college friends Peyton turns out
he has become rich and influential just
like all their classmates this makes
John and Alice feel even worse but they
can at least enjoy free drinks which is
a rare luxury for them these days the
next day John wakes up with a bad
hangover and throws up since he drank a
lot of free alcohol don't forget it's a
luxury Alice goes to get him some lime
water but realizes that the refrigerator
is empty no water even hence they decide
to go to the market with whatever money
they have on the way they get into an
accident but fortunately both of them
are left unharmed shortly after as John
is chatting with the police Alice
notices an old woman fetching a shiny
teapot from the garbage there's an
antique store just nearby curious she
hastily crosses the road narrowly
avoiding a car and goes inside the store
there she chats with the lady for a
while and praises the artifacts on
display but when the lady gets
distracted by a phone call Alice steals
the glowing teapot and runs away from
there John is stunned to see his wife
stealing something for the first time
but in response Alice says that she is
only borrowing it the following day John
heads out for his office while Alice
irons her hair as she is engrossed over
the phone she accidentally Burns her
head I'm starting to understand why she
doesn't have a job the same time the
teapot mysteriously moves and when Alice
opens the lid she finds some money
inside this shocks her big time wanting
to know how the money got there Alice
repeats what she did earlier that is she
intentionally Burns her head through her
Delight the teapot again coughs up some
money with this Revelation Alice starts
hurting herself in different ways and
the more pain she suffers the more cash
the teapot poops out meanwhile Jon's
boss fires him for not achieving the
selling Target he returns home with
disappointment and finds his wife lying
unconscious bruised and scarred scared
he tries calling for help but Alice
suddenly gets up and says that she's
okay Jon then reveals that he was fired
by his boss and in response Alice slaps
him hard across the face this puzzles
the poor guy but his mood quickly
changes when Alice shows him the money
in the teapot this reveals the
mysterious artifact will dispense money
if either one of the couple gets hurt
Alice explains all this to Jon but as
expected he doesn't believe it to prove
herself she kicks her husband brutally
and the teapot gives out an even bigger
of cash this finally convinces Jon and
so the couple spend the whole night
hurting each other physically at one
point they become so tired that Jon
starts having doubts about the but he
believes that it is going to break apart
their relationship and cause even deeper
problems for them Alice who is clearly
the greedier of the tale explains that
they will throw the teapot away when
they earn one million dollars but John
is not convinced the next morning while
Alice is asleep Jon takes the teapot
back to the store however there is no
one inside so he takes the pot to an
antique roadshow instead the valuator
calculates that the teapot is worth five
thousand dollars but this is far less
than what John had expected so he
returns back home with it meanwhile as
the teapot is shown on the television a
guy named Dr Ling notices it and plans
to meet Jon for some unknown reason in
the next scene we see that the couple is
back to their usual greedy ways they
intentionally burn their hands on a gas
stove to make more money they also
indulge in other sorts of painful
activities like waxing tooth extraction
without anesthesia getting tattoos and
some kinky stuff in bed oh all this
while the pot keeps on discharging money
making them Rich the couple stashes all
the money in their bath as they don't
want to pay taxes the following day they
are joined by Alice's family for dinner
everyone makes fun of Alice for not
having a child and being jobless wow but
once they notice the lavish items around
the house they curiously inquire what
John is doing in response he jokingly
says that he's in a real estate later
John and Alice celebrate the clearing of
their debts they cannot believe that
they have completely turned their lives
around with the help of a mere teapot as
the two continue celebrating there is a
sudden knock on the door when John goes
to inspect two Jewish Brothers suddenly
barge inside and beat him up cha-ching
they have come looking for the teapot
which apparently belonged to their
grandmother the poor woman had been
protecting it since the Holocaust but
last week when it got stolen she became
so depressed that she passed away due to
a heart attack now the brothers have
come to retrieve the teapot and take it
home however Alice lies that she already
sold it some days ago in an auction she
has even spent half the money on makeup
products when the brothers hear this
they angrily ask for the rest of the
money in response Alice sneakily grabs
some cat of the teapot that it made from
John's beating she then hands it over to
the brothers prompting them to finally
leave the place after the close call
John and Alice decide to learn more
about the teapot they go to an old
library and find a book containing
information about it as Alice goes
through it alone she finds something
shocking in one of the pages and tears
it out without Jon's Knowledge from the
rest of the book they learned that the
teapot is from the time of Christ and it
has extraordinary powers with unsavory
consequences Jon becomes worried and
tries to find the page about the
consequences but Alice who is already
torn it out lies that it isn't there
later they buy a fancy car a massive
house in a wealthy neighborhood and a
John even starts a vodka label in his
name they even host a party in their new
place and invite all of their rich
friends in the middle of the festivities
Dr Ling suddenly arrives at the door
claiming Jon and Alice are in grave
danger he says he is from a community
which deals with ancient artifacts and
magic and that he is interested in
buying the teapot Jon becomes intrigued
by the offer and contempt selling it but
his greedy wife shuts the door on Lang
and sends him away the following night
as John and Alice are beating and
hurting each other for cash Arnie
notices them and learns about the
teapot's powers as a result he barges
inside their house steals the teapot and
runs away Jon follows him outside and
the two engage in a minor tussle this
results in the teapot being thrown on
the road and soon after a truck runs
over it but to everyone's surprise the
teapot is still intact it hasn't even
sustained a single scratch this finally
makes the couple realize that they are
dealing with some Supernatural stuff so
the very next morning they seek out Dr
Lang for help the latter explains that
owning the teapot will always result in
something bad as all of its previous
owners have either committed the
unthinkable or been murdered he further
reveals that the teapot makes its owners
greedy forcing them to commit
unimaginable and heinous acts Dr Ling
then tries to persuade the couple to
hand it over to him claiming that there
is still time to save themselves however
John and Alice once again refuse and
walk away later at night Alice suddenly
wakes up and realizes that someone is
broken into their house she quickly
informs Jon about it and when they head
downstairs they find the Jewish Brothers
stealing all of their money scared John
brings forward the teapot and offers it
to them but the brothers refuse one of
them reveals that they never wanted the
teapot in the first place as they know
it only brings pain and suffering they
came here for the money and nothing else
saying all of this the brothers walk
away from the house the following day
John and Alice wake up completely broke
to make matters worse the teapot has
stopped giving cash since it has grown
accustomed to small injuries and
beatings now it demands more pain and
suffering desperate the couple walks
into a bar where John intentionally
picks a fight with a tough guy as he
gets knocked out cold the teapot finally
dispenses money making Alice happy one
day while Alice is at the park she
notices the pot producing money when a
local skater falls off and gets hurt
this makes her realize that they can
earn money without even hurting
themselves she tells Jon about the
incident and they visit different places
like like UFC matches and the Maternity
Ward where a woman is giving birth to a
child this starts taking a toll on the
couple's psyche especially Alice who
becomes greedy and desires more and more
money one day while on their way home
she intentionally tries to run a man
over to make a lot of cash but
fortunately Jon takes over the steering
in the nick of time and prevents the
accident he then scolds her for being
crazy and in response Alice also hurled
some curse words at him when they reach
home they are stunned to find the pot
filled with cash this makes them realize
that the teapot also dispends his money
for emotional pain hence they resort to
badmouthing each other every day
believing that it is easier than hurting
themselves the next morning the couple
sits down and prepares to break each
other's heart at first they open up
about their extramarital Affairs and how
they had one-night stands with other
people when Alice says that she slept
with Arnie Jon gets Furious and decides
to take revenge he goes straight to
Arnie's house and curses at his wife to
their surprise the teapot once again
releases cash indicate stating that the
trick works with other people's emotions
as well but this information the couple
starts meeting their friends and
relatives to reveal their darkest
Secrets this severs their relationships
with a lot of people but they couldn't
care less this is a perfect analogy for
being a twitch streamer one day Alice
decides to take things to a different
level she plans on killing a sex
offender or a drug dealer to make more
money Jon tries to object but Alice
eventually convinces him by saying that
these people are the scum of society and
they don't deserve to live later as they
are digging a grave John has a sudden
change of heart and tries to stop his
wife he reminds Alice of the evil that
the teapot has drawn out of her however
she brushes him aside and declares that
she is not going to stop she will carry
out the murder with or without his help
hearing this a panicked John rushes to
Dr Ling for help but the latter claims
that it is already too late the teapot
has taken over us and corrupted her mind
there is only one way to stop all of
this though Alice has to willingly hand
over the teapot to him later as Alice
comes out of the shower she notices Jon
on the window he is holding the paper
that Alice had previously torn out of
the book mentioning the unsavory
consequences John asks her to choose
between him and the teapot when she
doesn't say anything he throws himself
out the window the site sends Alice into
a state of panic and she quickly rushes
to check up on her husband fortunately
he is alive and well this finally makes
Alice realize what a bad person she has
become she tearfully confesses that her
life and all the money would be
meaningless without Jon's presence so
she decides to get rid of the teapot
however later at night Arnie breaks into
their house yet again and takes the
teapot away the couple find out about
the theft the following day and
immediately suspect that Arnie has taken
it they rushed to the police and find it
completely trashed moreover both Arnie
and his wife are covered in cuts and
bruises it appears that they went
through the same ordeal our protagonist
couple went through some weeks before at
the same time the Jewish Brothers also
arrive at the scene and an intense
shootout in Zeus Arnie and his wife
along with the Jewish brothers are
killed on the spot but John and Alice
survive they quickly grabbed the teapot
and the cash made out of the four deaths
before fleeing the scene and after a
while they approached Dr Lang and
finally hand the teapot over to him this
marks the end of their curse and now
they are finally free the movie ends as
Dr Ling takes the teapot and throws it
away into the sea where no one can find
it
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching